Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to the video where I try not to pla-
WOOOAH.
(570M VIEWS?)
What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna try
*NOT*
To play..
*Minecraft*
Because there's nothing about Minec-
*Mark gawking at the amounts of views*
*Uh..*
*You alright there, Mark..?*
Oh boy, oh.
*Ah I see.*
*......*
*Mark has lost his mind-*
Yeah but there's definitely not like, a demand for it.
(Oh you have no idea.)
*Mark sweating and panting at the amount of comments*
*Do.. do you need water?*
*I think he's about to pass out*
*Can someone call an ambulance?*
*There's someone having a heat stroke*
*No, just tell them to get here as quick as possible*
*Either he needs the E.R. or an asylum, I'm uh-*
*Well uh- asylum it is-*
Uh, man. I don't have to play it.
There's nothing good about it, there's nothing-
*stifling*
There's nothing good about it-
*Mark struggling to keep his composure*
*Okay, he's completely lost it.*
Okay it can't be that-
WOAHOHO-
Hohoh-
WoaHOH-
Erhoh-
wOAhHH-
UTAH- HUH?
Utah loves it some Minecraft.
Utah loves *digging* so-
That makes sense.
'Kay maybe Colorado is here-
*YEAAOH*
Hohohoh-
*NICE*
How about Minecraft vs-
Five-
*keyboard ASMR*
Can't be more popular than any-
GoHOHAH-
*Mark astonished by how insane he's becoming*
*Mom, can you pick me up, I'm scared*
Ah- That's not even close.
That's not even close. [x2]
That's not even close. [x3]
That's not even- HO HAH-
Hohkay- It's basically DONE.
*OOF*
Erkay, alright, how about-
*Oh he won't be too happy about this-*
*Mojang [ ︻デ═一 ] BUMBUM*
Ah, it's fine-
Hmm- uhh-
MMM!
*Yes, PORN*
That's true-
WHA-?
...
Wait..
*Mark.exe is having technical difficulties*
OH porn's wi-
Okay, porn-
*PORN WINS*
I thought for a second there was a dip in porn usage
due to Minecraft.
(I mean, Minecraft porn-)
"Interest in porn."
MISSISSIPPIIIIII
MRS.
SIPPYYYY
UTAAAAAAH
KILLIN' IT WITH THE MINECRA- *devolves into laughter*
Alright, okay, that's unfair.
(Also because Minecraft porn-)
Okay, um-
How about-
Fortnite-
Can't be more popular than fort-
*ominous music*
*OH SHIT IT IS*
Oh no..
Oh.. *chuckling* Okay..
*AAAAAAA*
Okay, whatever it's- it's fine
It's fine.
I won't do it, I won't do it.
I won't do it, you can't make me do it.
You can't-
I can't-
I won't-
I'm not-
I don't fall to peer pressure.
I don't.
I don't do it.
I don't fall-
(But you do fall for that CASH tho.)
*Mark failing to attempt to suffocate himself by forcing air out of his lungs*
*Mark, you're concerning me, please stop-*
*JESUS CHRIST, SEEK MEDICAL ATTENTION*
*cough cough*
*cough*
*hack*
*choke*
*lungs collapsing*
*death*
*struggling*
No, I can't.
You can't make me do it.
(Well, yes but actually no.)
*constipated*
I'm not gonna do it.
Don't make me do it.
*Make him do it*